from mit we will continue uh hearing
about optimization on manifolds and in
particular soviet will talk about
geodesic convexity and optimization i'm
sure it's going to be a great talk so
enjoy
okay
thank you arena and
uh sorry that i couldn't uh make it in
person due to last minute travel hick
hacks so
uh but it's great uh
we are all set and
you have already a really cool
introduction to optimization and many of
the things that have been talked about
you
have seen in one way or the other i just
want to
share with you just some definitions
some examples
some motivation and
if
if time permits
i'll try to go through one quick proof
just to see how things
actually how to use use these tools
and i'm going to talk about
in fact one of my favorite topics i've
been
i ran into the concept of geodesic
convexity
from a very very very different very
pragmatic angle
and i kind of
i used to work on bunch of applications
in computer vision and
statistical modeling and whatnot
and i ended up working on some
optimization problems where
all the time no matter what i was doing
the
software used to always give the same
solution and these were non-convex
problems clearly
and i thought what's going on this
happened for one problem two problems
three problems and then i thought maybe
there is something special going on and
i collected a list of such problems and
this is the time when i did not
really know
what romanian manifolds are other than i
had heard the word manifolds and then i
kind of
ran into the concept of geodesic
convexity and then i understood that
okay geodesic convexity is what
underlies the success of all these
applications that i was working on and
since then
i kind of got fascinated with this topic
and i hope to share
at least an epsilon of my fascination
with this topic with you uh with my hope
being to interest you
to look deeply into a huge number of
open problems that crop out of just the
geodesically convex segment of the large
world of optimization
and
just as a preview
within this big picture
kind of the focus is on different
convexity structures and in particular
you know the standard ones that we've
looked at convexity in vector spaces
special convex sets and the focus today
really that i will spend most of my time
will be on the
setup of
manifolds
and there are other
settings where convexity structures pop
up
like metric spaces and whatnot and for
me they have popular popped up in a
variety of
application domains where i have been
directly or indirectly involved
so
the
bigger motivation is to you know just
take
just like convexity has been such a
powerful modeling tool in all of
optimization to now also think that okay
can we now
look for an honest
true superset of the concept of
convexity
to look at how we can now expand our
modeling repertoire of modeling
non-convex problems which may be
non-complex in the original formulation
but possess some kind of hidden
convexity where this hidden convexity
can be elicited through the language of
geometry through either romanian
geometry or through some other geometry
and
once you can elicit this hidden
convexity then you really have
learned
how to potentially potentially
tractively attack
a non-convex problem that may otherwise
have appeared computationally infeasible
at first sight
so that's kind of really the story
and i'm going to very briefly comment
just to pique your interest because we
don't really have that much time if we
had like a couple of days we could talk
more about
all the 50 different flavors of
convexity that i have run into during my
work
but i'll focus on one but i'll still to
pique your interest i'll touch a little
bit upon convexity in metric spaces
coming from the following very simple
picture my favorite picture of this
topic just the idea of convexity let's
look at it abstractly so you have two
points
x and y and then join them with a
straight line
and you look at
this line segment between x and y
and a straight line you can write it as
1 minus t x plus t y that's the red dot
in the middle
and
you can say let's look at the function f
which
where this plus refers to just that
thing where f at an intermediate point
is interpolated or is the arithmetic
average of the f at the end points
that's the definition of convexity along
the line
and by now actually the what i'm about
to say next should be obvious to you
because we are
speaking geometry
if you
have the same property
along a curve
does not have to be a straight line in
space anymore it's some curve
parameterized by t
but along each point of that curve you
have the same
inequality you get curved convexity if
that curve happens to be
a geodesic
joining two points on a manifold then
you'll get geodesic convexity
that's all and this is an
ancient concept starting formally with
the
not in the same language but starting
formally with carl menger's phd thesis
in 1918 since then it has seen a lot of
development in mathematics
and the beauty of course once you have
convexity structures you get this luxury
that
local optima are global
optimum and that's the reason now you
have a much richer notion of convexity
so
even though i'm talking geometry i do
like to think sometimes in this purely
algebraic manner that you know
the arithmetic average along a line is
replaced by some kind of
geometric or non-geometric average along
the curve but you still have the same
inequality you get a generalized notion
of convexity
and
this notion of convexity
does
has been studied in great detail in
metric spaces so we get something called
geodesic convexity in metric spaces
and
[Music]
this is now one step
more general than many folds
so you can talk about general metric
spaces of course there's all sorts of
pathological things but some of the
nicest metric spaces are so called
geodesic metric spaces
where
what you have where you have geodesics
for instance and what's the geodesic
path whose length equals the distance
between its end points distance function
is what we need to define a metric space
so if you have a metric space where you
can create paths whose length is equal
to the distance between the endpoints
then you have a geodesic metric space
and it has a very amongst many excluding
pathologies one of the nicest
definitions that i originally ran into
and found useful is
this midpoint property which is
essentially suggested by midpoint
convexity in jensen's inequality
is that for any pair of points x and y
where x is different from y let's say
there exists a midpoint m
which is essentially halfway between x
and y
and one can take that
adding some you know completeness blah
blah type of things assumptions to
really define what is the geodesic
matrix space where this midpoint
property holds
and examples are things like normal
vector spaces demanding manifolds more
general fixed level many four so called
cats 0 spaces etc etc etc
and the history is quite interesting
actually
if now you can define moreover if you
can define unique geodesics
then
you enter the business of convexity much
more seriously and you can do much more
and haram
realized long ago that convexity of the
distance function the distance function
that
gives us the metric space if that
distance function is convex along the
geodesics along its geodesics then you
can define
this matrix convexity nicely on this
metric space
and so this is just like a very high
level quick rush to brush through and
we're not gonna dwell too much on that
but i just wanted to mention that
because this kind of connects to and
touches upon some of the upcoming things
in this entire
semester including maybe the boot camp
on sampling tomorrow
is
uh i i just copy pasted this from
williams famous book on optimal
transport chapter 16. please read that
chapter on the topic of displacement
convexity he gives a kind of a
casual and quick introduction to the
idea of geodesic convexity in metric
spaces
and
essentially he's just talking the same
thing if you can define geodesics for
which the convexity inequality holds you
get geodesic convexity but there's a
book reference to that
and
this particular version of convexity
when working with vasa stein spaces i'm
just using keywords no time to describe
those because you will see these
upcoming in the next few days i'm sure
you get something that is called
displacement convexity which is just
another kind of
another word for this type of geodesic
convexity so i just wanted to throw it
out here the geodesic convexity shows up
in various different places uh it shows
up in certain combinatorial spaces which
are cats many of them are cat zero
spaces it shows up in romanian manifolds
it shows up in finsler manifolds in some
other spaces and it shows up as
displacement convexity in vasa style
space which is
uh manifests into you know all sorts of
important connections
to sampling concentration of measure and
other such tools
so there's some kind of convexity always
there so this was the super high level
zip through on the idea of geodesic
convexity
and i'm gonna actually spend more time
talking about some simple
more concrete down-to-earth motivating
examples and definitions that i have run
into in my own research
so in particular
now that
nicola's lecture is fresh in your minds
they may just use the terminology he
defined and kind of defined already
so
let's look at the notion of geodesic
convexity on romanian manifolds
so just remember
nicola use retraction i i'm using a
distinguished kind of retraction called
an exponential map it is intimately
related to geodesics you don't have to
worry
let's talk intuitively so in vector
space you can take x and add to it a
vector v you get x plus
its remaining analog is
to
look at the tangent vector v
in the tangent space rooted at point x
and using that non-linear map you land
back on the manifold
and using that exponential matrices
retraction also does that for you
exponential map is a distinguished kind
of retraction and its inverse operation
is called the inverse exponential map
and you can think that it simulates for
you
uh difference of vectors
so if you join x to y
this quantity is the difference vector y
minus x and the same picture there is
the exponential map
if you want a mnemonic which is i think
a useful mnemonic i find for remembering
which way subtraction uh you may like to
keep this mnemonic in mind
x x inverse y
whatever
our luck is i read it from
right to left
y minus x so if you
that's one mnemonic to remember whenever
you're doing lots of calculations
especially when you're doing it
for the first time it's hard to remember
you know whether this is x minus y or y
minus x and of course
uh if you make a mistake of sign then
that destroys convexity so this is a
useful mnemonic to read it from right to
left
okay
so here is just the rimanian geodesic
convexity so
let gamma
join x to y
which means gamma of 0 is x and gamma of
1 is y that's what i mean by this
notation and it's let's say unique
shortest path uh unique geodesic joining
x to y
i just write it in this mnemonic
notation with a
circle plus
these are points on manifolds you can't
add them it's just a mnemonic to remind
you that this is just a point one minus
t along the geodesic then
this is really the definition of
geodesic convexity
that we looked at already
and now in the case of romanian
manifolds you can actually also write
the following
familiar definition the gradient or sub
gradient based definition of convexity
is f x is bigger than f y plus
gradient
f this is the romanian gradient i'm just
writing nabla anyways sorry
for that abuse
and you can see this is x minus y
so that's just the usual definition and
that holds here for geodesic convexity
and this is the
inner product at the tangent space of y
this is an object that both of these
objects live in the tangent space y
so that's the definition
and similarly you can define something
like strong convexity where
you get
distance function square
with a parameter mu if mu is equal to
zero you get the usual weak convexity if
mu is strictly bigger than zero you get
strong geodesic convexity these are very
much similar to the euclidean notions
with the euclidean objects now replaced
with romanian objects
in
similarly lip shapes continuity if f is
just continuous
same thing right ellipsis continuity we
can define in general anyways in metric
spaces like this
and
this is the version of
l smooth gradients
where this else and you already saw
with this this is the
one-way retraction that nikola had
written
uh this is the canonical version of l
smoke gradients that we use
this can be written in kind of fanciful
notation
gradient f of y minus you have to use
parallel transport
from x to y gradient
but that's kind of a distraction for now
so just want to say here at this point
that
in some sense when you first touch the
remaining optimization problem and
nikola has already taken you through
that even if you're using geodesic
convexity my advice would be to just
first go through the mechanics of seeing
which equilibrium concept do i translate
into a romanian concept
and actually man of toolbox is awesome
for that
i i cannot like recommend it enough
definitely play with it it's really well
done toolbox
and you can see you look into the source
code of it and you'll just quickly see
that ah okay this is how you translate
the concepts and it will already
actually work through some of those for
at least for sub manifolds
and
once you can do that you can actually
without understanding anything of course
program things and so why do we even
need to understand and that's where i
want to spend more of the time today
that's fine you know we can do the
translation almost mechanically and plug
and play and things work out but we'd
like to do a little bit more science and
look into what's going on and what can
we say and how can we take advantage of
geodesic convexity
and what
great open concerns does it pose for us
so
let me give you that so a concrete
example nikola already warned you that
this is coming up
this just happens to be
my personal favorite
manifold because i guess i
really discovered the concept of g
convexity when struggling with problems
where
the constraint was x is x transpose or
hermitian conjugate and x is strictly
positive definite
and
there is a very distinguished choice of
riemannian metric that
actually
we will work with and
with the suitable choice of romanian
metric
those functions that i am going to talk
about look convex
so you may in some sense also see
not in some sense you know this can be
made mathematically rigorous
with a suitable romanian metric
your problem may actually look
geodesically convex if the riemann
metric is not suitable then the problem
may not look geodesically convex
and you can take even a very high level
kind of
intuitive step
and one can make even a more sweeping
claim but this is just an existence kind
of vacuous claim still
that if your problem
within a certain set
has a unique minimum and functions are
uh differentiable etcetera
but it's non-convex in the euclidean
sense there always exists a ramanian
metric under which your function will
look compacts geodesically come back so
it's kind of a canonical notion
and your pst manifold
so it's motivated by just this super
simple thing
so down to earth stuff
you know log of one plus x is a concave
function i plotted it there everybody
knows it's a concave function on the
positive line right
however
that's if you use
straight lines but if instead we know
this is log
if you use a multiplicative curve so
rather than taking arithmetic average of
x and y
after all 1 minus t x plus t y is
arithmetic average
if you take geometric average
then this function satisfies this
convexity property
and these types of convex functions by
the way were already studied by
jensen in his famous 1905 paper where he
introduced the janssen's inequality x7
the one with f of the arithmetic average
got best known the other ones were not
that deeply studied
so
this is geodesically convex under that
geodesic there exists the riemann metric
for which this geometric average of x
and y will be the geodesic and f
satisfies that property log of 1 plus x
is a very very important function
because it's essentially the building
block of log of 1 plus e to the x the
so-called logistic loss logistic
function which is central to all of
machine learning
so on for positive definite matrices
something very interesting
under a suitable rimanian metric
there exists a romanian metric it's so
called
uh some people call it the fischer rao
metric
because people in statistics studied it
and it goes by many other names i'll
just call it the
usual rimanian metric
the geodesic
between two matrices x and y
takes on a beautiful closed form
it is given by exactly the
non-commutative analog of
x to the 1 minus t y to the t but
because positive these are symmetric
positive definite matrices when you take
this object you can't just
write that
you have to take this kind of
products to ensure that you get a
symmetric result out so this happens to
be the geodesic
and now if along this
non-linear curve
f satisfies this convexity inequality
you get geodesic convexity for positive
definite matrices and i love it because
of course matrices don't mute that's
where all the math becomes interesting
and open problems start popping up
so some examples just for concreteness
condition number
very important quantity of matrix it's a
ratio of largest eigen value so here by
the way x is strictly psp okay ratio of
largest eigen value to smallest eigen
value this is known to be euclidean
quasi convex
but it actually turns out to be
geodesically convex
much harder result
generalized eigenvalue of two pst
matrices
is lambda max a comma b is given as
lambda max of a inverse b so it's a
product of two matrices usually when we
take products we destroy convexity you
ordinary convexity right so this is also
known to be euclidean quasi-convex and
that is the result that comes up in
lmi and control theory of back in the
day but it turns out that this quantity
also is geodesically convex along the
geodesic i showed on the previous slide
that's a somewhat
harder result to prove but whatever
and
log of trace of x to the p
for p any real number that is also
geodesically cut back so these are some
very i think
standard objects that one runs into
while doing optimization and even though
they are non-convex through the
euclidean lens they do have this
hidden geodesic convexity which is
really cool and there's many more
examples like this in a paper
that we wrote in 2015
which
constructs gives you bunch of tools for
recognizing and constructing
geodesically convex functions on
positive definite matrices
you could of course use those
tautological definitions that i showed
you or you know look at the riemannian
hessian is semi-definite etc but those
are typically algebraically quite
monstrous to deal with but if you have a
bunch of lemmas that you can use to
generate and recognize uh g convex
functions that can greatly
ease your job so for positive definite
matrices uh
this work does that and one of the most
interesting corollaries there is
this particular corollary
that the log depth
of this object b is a psd pst
semi-definite matrix a i
is a general complex matrix can be
rectangular but has a kind of full
column rank
that particular log that object is
geodesically convex and
why that is super fascinating uh
here is one reason two three reasons
log net of x is the
uh you know plus of log debt of x is the
entropy of a gaussian fundamental object
in sampling concentration
so minus log that x also happens to be
the canonical
barrier function in interior point
theory and log that of x
so it's a from x minus log that is
convex so log that is concave and even
though it is concave it happens to be
geodesically compacts and log net has
many other fascinating properties that
come up in theory all the time so it's
kind of remarkable it has this uh
wonderful
hidden geodesic convexity property
and mention a toy application of that
soon enough
okay
any any question comments so far i kind
of uh i'm trying to no puns intended
zoom through the talk
so just as additional motivation so that
we don't only spend a bulk of bulk of my
time in uh abstract theorems let me show
share with you some concrete examples
there's motivation where geodesic
convexity was helpful in a variety of
ways
and the variety of ways include
it could be either helpful because
it
allows us to build a new mathematical
model for an old problem
and
or
it ends up having better conditioning
properties so we are able to numerically
solve something better
or
it ends up
geodesic and vaccine quotes
uh it ends up
explaining
the success of an existing method which
was previously analyzed through
euclidean lens so because now you have
this new tool you can use it for various
purposes right for modeling for
algorithm design for whatever so i just
want to share some very simple examples
with you as motivation there
the first one is a machine learning
example
and it's one of my favorite examples
actually
and so let's
uh look at this example it's a very
simple canonical problem called linear
metric learning and linear metric
learning is a precursor of what is
studied these days in machine learning
under the word of contrastive learning
where you have full-blown neural
networks and blah blah etc in place so
linear metric learning what does it do
it says well if i have input data and i
just plot it
using the raw input vectors that i have
things may look mixed up
however
if we had some way to judge
whether two points are similar or close
to each other or dissimilar or far from
each other that would really
simplify the job of doing classification
and hence building a machine learning
system right
so metric learning says that well
what if we learn a distance function so
that things that are similar
like closer to each other and things
that are different from each other they
lie far apart can we do that
and linear metric learning
says
i'll use i'll just learn
[Music]
a simple
euclidean metric that's what's called
linear metric learning
and it says
suppose i observe pairs of points that
are supposed to be
similar
and pairs of points that are supposed to
be different
now instead of using
x minus y
as the square distance between points or
rather x i minus x j
i say that let's use
use a linear transformation
and x i l transpose x j and now measure
the distance
if a is written as
ll transpose that exactly turns into
this mahalanobis distance
and the job of metric learning becomes
then to learn a positive definite matrix
a
and you can use this cholesky factor to
transform the points if you want
so that's what metric learning does it's
a really cool problem which was
introduced in a very influential paper
by
eric singh mike jordan peter
russell and enduring
and since then
this important problem had a lot of
traction and machine learning and people
still continue to use metric learning
and it has inspired the more recent
learning
unsupervised learning thing in machine
learning which is a hot topic by the way
these days
so the original formulations of metric
learning were all convex
ssdp because we are learning a psd
matrix let's set up an stp
after that there was an influential
paper by weinberg and saul which tried
to write another sdp based on the large
margin principle and then
my colleagues and i worked on it back in
the day using an information theoretic
bregman divergence based motivation and
so on and there's tons of other works
i forget from when is this
not that recent maybe
in any case there's lots of convex
formulations and the reason i'm showing
you this is
at the time this was done at the time
this was done it's just a lesson in
history
people recognize okay psg so psd
constraints it'll be good to write
things as a convex program because if we
model it using a convex program then we
have essentially unique answer robust
solution etc etc right so that led to
variety of convex formulations
and
then a few years ago
there was a student who wanted to work
on something geometric with me
and i said why don't you have a look at
this ancient problem and see if you can
do something geometric about it so i
just only said this much i didn't have
anything better to say that time
so
you may say that euclidean idea to look
at this problem
uh well we want to minimize the distance
between similar points so let's just sum
over those and we want to maximize the
distance between this similar point so
let's put a minus sign
add the two right
sounds like a canonical first thing to
try turns out to be a bad idea because
it can easily
it may not have a min like the minimum
value may go
down to minus infinity and it may give
you some degenerate solutions
so
that idea didn't work and in fact
because that idea didn't work is why
many of those original authors proposed
all those convex formulations
and
now a really cool thing the student who
was looking at it from a geometric eye
just did the let's say physics thing
and say that instead of putting a minus
there
let's keep a plus sign there but replace
a
by a inverse
using the intuition this is still
intuition so far you know if a is bigger
than b then a inverse is less than b
inverse is opposite for positive numbers
so
one way to expand the distance
could be to use a inverse for dissimilar
points whereas to use a for similar
points so this is all intuitive so far
but something really cool happens
and that is collect all the similar
points into a matrix s which is a
scatter matrix of similar points defined
like that
just you know the scatter matrix of
similar and dissimilar points
common objectives statistics and
clustering
and you write the cost function like
this
trace of a s plus trace of a inverse d
this is really the
d a of x i x j for similar points
because there's some mahalanobis
distance it's just a linear object in a
is the variable right
so this is really cool because this
problem is actually both convex and as a
side remark it happens to be also
geodesically convex and something
cool is about to happen and that's the
reason why i really like this particular
example
is
well pretend your constraint set is open
so
you can take the euclidean gradient set
it to zero
and that's the problem was actually
strictly convex so that suffices to get
the globally optimal solution
setting the gradient of that equal to
zero you can verify it was trace of you
know a s plus trace of a inverse
d
you can go to matrix calculus dot org
and type this in to get this gradient
out if you don't want to differentiate
yourself
you'll see you get this equation this is
a non-linear matrix equation for people
in control they may recognize this as a
regard to equation and in fact that
equation has a closed form solution
and that's where things became very
interesting for us because
it turns out that closed form solution
is given by
the midpoint of
geodesic between s inverse and d where
the geodesic was given by this formula
that we saw long ago
so when that happened then
we thought oh i see so maybe
remaining geometric way to formulate
linear metric learning is probably
a good way to do it
and the solution it just emerged out of
the solution so you know this was we're
not even
it only started with saying let's just
think geometrically that's all so i
think if that's one takeaway from my
lecture i think i'll be happy
just it's okay to
think geometrically what is the right
geometry to impose we don't know but at
least get thinking in terms of geometry
and
you may profit
and actually it turns out
more generally you can
find an a
that lies on
the geodesic between s inverse and d
doesn't necessarily have to be the
midpoint and more importantly
computing this
is a non-convex problem
but it is solvable to global optimality
or if you solve it it's globally optimal
thanks to
strict geodesic convexity
and
all of this is so far okay
mathematically pleasing but you know the
coolest thing that happened was that
actually if you try it out on
uh
machine learning data sets by comparing
it with the state of the art linear
metric learning methods we're not
talking about the metric learning here
it actually
is as accurate or more accurate but
thousands of times faster because thanks
to geometry you got a close form
solution
and as a by-product
if you think in terms of statistics you
may see that you may think of this
closed form as being some kind of
supervised whitening transform of your
data
and we go you got get all these nice
byproducts just by thinking geometric
so i kind of rushed through that example
but i hope kind of you get my excitement
about
the the power of geometry
okay a purely theoretical example that
i'll
quickly mention
and the reason i'll mention this is i'll
tell you maybe i'll tell it to you after
i mention it right away so
a big generalization of
inequalities you know fundamental
inequalities like holders inequality
young's inequality that we use all the
time in information theory probability
theory or analysis etc is so-called
brass comp leap inequality which
basically says
you know the sum of products is upper
bounded by the product of sums up to
some constant
that's what we typically do when we do
this holder inequalities right sums of
products is bounded by product of sums
etc
and so this is the grandest
generalization of those
and in that inequality there is a
constant which is known as brass
complete constant which is known to be
given by
the solution of this optimization
problem
getting the tightest such constant
was important to some applications in
geometric complexity theory that i
learned from
ankit and avi
many years ago in fact at simon's uh we
talked about this topic in that time and
this is
this brass complete constant and brass
complete theory has been deeply studied
in probability and other areas
multi-linear analysis and whatnot so no
time to get into that and there are
people at berkeley who have looked at
this way more deeply than i have i'm in
the breast complete theory
so
the cool point was that actually
this non-convex optimization problem is
actually a g-convex optimization problem
and that simple recognition
is actually just a corollary of some
ancient results of ours
but that recognition opens the way
to
address
this problem in geometric complexity
theory
via the lengths of g convexity so which
ties things very nicely and in fact i if
i'm not wrong
what
these guys were really after
is
to get a fast
algorithm
to solve this problem to epsilon
accuracy
in
log 1 by epsilon iterations
and that
opens the way to
that opens a variety of really cool
theoretical open problems in g-convex
optimization
so
this was a kind of surprising connection
and i'm kind of zipping through
everything because
i really really want to also go through
the proof so i may actually sacrifice
one of my
motivating examples which
but let me not sacrifice a
classical example which is also example
that nikola talked about
is suppose you're trying to do pca
find the largest eigenvector largest
principal component
and here i'm just stressing large
datasets because that's the context
within which i look but you don't
necessarily have to limit yourself to
large you can also look at small data
sets
is this particular problem right
you observe the zi's and the covariance
suppose they are centered so
covariance of these and you want to get
the largest eigenvector i like to write
everything as minimization because i'm a
convex
optimization kind of person so all my
problems are written as minimization
and i'm trying to solve it
now you can analyze this if you want to
solve it for n really large
your practical hope is to actually use
stochastic gradient methods but this is
this is a non-linear constraint so what
people were doing is to do stochastic
gradient and after each stochastic
gradient step
do this retraction
to pull it back on the sphere
so we thought well maybe then one can
understand this this is one of the most
ancient uses of riemannian optimization
anyways through the romanian lens
and
you can bypass a lot of the euclidean
machinery
and get a much simpler mathematical
analysis of the same method that
everybody else is analyzing by doing
it through a geometric lens through
romanian lens and
in particular
a very nice property is satisfied by
this cost function
it's not really geodesically convex but
it is kind of like geodesically strongly
convex because it satisfies the
so-called
policy which inequality on the sphere
so it's romanian gradient satisfies that
strong convexity like properties which
basically is a sufficient condition to
ensure that you can solve non-convex
problems to global optimality
and that ends up telling you
that romanian sgt will succeed etc etc
so this is just an application of
essentially g g convex like theory
so these are just some motivating
applications i think i'll skip my boston
mixture model example where
g convexity played a very essential role
but
in the interest of time let me just skip
that
and
actually come to theory so that i have
some time for the theory but i like to
pause here because i went a bit fast in
case anybody wants to say anything
please you're welcome too
okay maybe now we come to the easy part
so let me go through that a little
slowly so that maybe you have something
to uh
wonder about
so let's look at some theory i looked at
so just to summarize where where are we
so i mentioned that convexity structures
occur in a variety of spaces
manifolds vector spaces metric spaces i
briefly described to you geodesic
convexity and i point to deeper
reference where you can read more about
convexity and vector spaces
and then we looked at some idea of
convexity in romanian manifolds and then
i showed you just
convexity on my favorite remarkable
manifold and some motivating
applications where convexity played
directly or indirectly played a role
either for the mathematical modeling or
for designing a faster algorithm or for
attacking a complexity theoretical
question
so now
let's look at
theory
for
q
for what
for
optimization
and optimization algorithms so let's
pretend that the theory of g convexity
recognizing constructing def defining
etc has already been done so the
interest now is
how to use that to analyze optimization
so here is the aim and that's part of
really my ongoing research since many
years
is to develop
global complexity theory
for
first order optimization of geodesically
convex functions and let's first limit
ourselves to
let's say
romanian manifolds
and even there limit ourselves to
what are called aramad manifolds
which is
globally
non-positive
curvature
so curvy so i just limit myself to that
setting uh because of that comment of uh
aramart that you know if the distance
function is globally convex you can
define global convexity
so all those definitions of geodesic
convexity that i stated for them to hold
on the entire space
you need
this global non-positive curvature if
you're positive curvature like the
sphere because geodesics are not really
going to be unique you can add more
geodesic convexity locally in some
region
but not globally and to simplify
analysis in the beginning
it's just okay to focus on this case
where you can have global convexity
and typically one assumes that the
manifolds curvature
is
bounded below it doesn't you know
degenerate down to minus infinity or
something
so
for the euclidean case
complexity of gradient descent
stochastic gradient descent accelerated
that all of those
they have been studied and well
developed you know by many many folks
but seminal work from
nimrovsky nude in 1983 who talked about
that oracle complexity of first order
optimization and
uh the new nestro has
of course discovered many of the
fundamental results there and we are
asking for a parallel of that theory
in redemandian land where you want to
understand both upper and lower bounds
so i'm only going to share with you an
upper bound
lower bounds
and having very precise lower bounds
are
an ongoing work of research and
there's many open questions there
so let me share with you some upper
bounds and i think that's really where i
want to go a little slowly
is
let's look at
our friend the sub gradient method
and
here
i'll do two things we'll look at really
by pattern matching to replace euclidean
concepts with romanian concepts
and then we'll see how far we get
and then at some point
we'll get stuck
and we'll have to do something honestly
romanian
to get unstuck
and hopefully that will give you
a little bit of flavor
for within the
context of geodesic convexity and
optimization
how
riemannian structure comes up and can
influence things
so
the most canonical optimization method
is this subgradient method right and
suppose uh g is
yes uh i'm forget and the cost function
is the f x
and g is some sub gradient
f is convex in the euclidean sense okay
euclidean sense everything is duplicated
on this slide
so
standard proof which you may have seen
already
is
by looking at
the distance
to the optimal point
at the t plus first iteration now plug
in
the definition of x t plus 1 in here
you get this
this is just the squared euclidean norm
so you can expand it
into this part
the cross product and that other square
right and now i rearrange
to take the
inner product term on the left hand side
and write it in terms of this difference
of distances and the
gradient term
i like this particular way because for
people who
do optimization analysis
you or anybody if you know if you do
induction ever which you definitely do
you you can smell
uh opportunity to telescope things here
because the difference of consecutive
positive quantities here
so that's the first step
then second step we invoke
this convexity definition f x minus f x
star
is less than equal to
g is a sub gradient
right at x t
so that's euclidean convexity
so now
you just plug that in
here
i just want wanted to write exactly the
same thing here i divided by eta you add
up over t and then divide by t to get
the average
so the t is with the first one sorry
and telescoping has happened things got
cancelled out
and
one more thing we plug in typically into
this analysis
we assume
for now for simplicity let's assume
that gt is uniformly bounded by
lf
so we assume that the cost function s is
lipschitz continuous so it's sub and so
its sub gradients are bounded like this
so we just replace this by that constant
just to simplify our life
right and
this quantity that we don't know what to
do with we give it another symbol called
diameter and we choose a step size
according to the ratio of the diameter
and the lip sheets constant all of these
are unknown quantities so it's just
science fiction we just write those
you plug that in and you get that the
average iterate
distance
and this is okay to do that because f of
the average iterate
by generation's inequality is less than
the average of these that's why we do
that is within o of 1 by root t so
that's the famous subgradient method
right
it's good to revisit that proof because
now
let's see what to do about it
so
this is the quantity which is the
starting point right and
this is the quantity that may kind of
bother us because
you can see that okay convexity
is this f minus f star
we could replace this with the
definition of g convexity
telescoping might just happen anyways
the norms may be replaced by demanding
distances right
so
we could do that
there's nothing else really special
happening so all the hard work will
happen in line one in some sense
right
so
let's try to do that hard work in line
in this area
so this is now the romanian version
of the sub gradient method
if f is differentiable then this is just
a unique nimanian gradient then it's
just remaining ingredient descent and
just writing sub gradient because it's
easier to
it's kind of more general easier to
explain also here
and
this is just the step one that i've
written here
this step is really from
the euclidean case
now
the
convexity part gets replaced by g
convexity
nothing special
um plug and play
the norms get replaced with ramanian
distances
and the
gradient part gets replaced with
something that i'm about to tell you so
you just trust me
everything else is mostly change of
notation and yes we'll end up getting
one by square root
so
where is the trouble well the trouble is
right here the distance square oops i
have an extra square here sorry about
that
so the distance square between x 3 plus
1 and x star
you plug in what is x t plus 1
is this quantity right
can we expand it
to
look like this
line here can we do that or not and
that's where we fail
so everything else was plug and play but
we already failed at step one so if we
could somehow come up with a proxy for
step one then we could build a theory of
at least first order optimization it
sounds seems promising
so
back to basics to high school
trigonometry so the euclidean law of
cosines was essential to bound
this distance right because
we came from x 0 we moved from x 0
somehow to x t
and in the analysis of this method we
have to see
x t was this far to x star
and from x t we go to x t plus 1 and x t
is plus 1 is this far
and this distances between these
these a b and c these three distances
they are related with each other in
terms of the angle a between
between these two sides
in other words you have a square is b
squared plus c squared minus 2 bc cos a
that's the law of cosines and written
out
a squared is this distance b squared is
this distance
this is the c squared term
and this this term corresponds to 2 bc
cos a
and
why our analysis failed is we don't have
this law of cosines in our curve space
and that was the motivating point for
my student honky was working on this
with me in 2016 to find
an analog for that and the analog was
that we don't have an exact equality but
in curved space
we have a curved
triangle and we can try to relate these
distances in terms of the curvature and
rather than have exact equality it uses
some important results in romanian
geometry called comparison theorems
and some other stuff
instead of getting equality at least we
get inequality that this distance
is upper bound in terms of
b square times some quantity that
depends on how curved your manifold is
and depending where you are capturing it
and the rest looks similar
and so kappa
is bound on the curvature so this is
sort of like x over tan h of x so as x
goes to zero this quantity goes to one
otherwise this is bigger
so you
have a v curve so instead of equality
you have a weaker inequality and it is
captured by really
the curvature of your space that's where
it comes in this is
uh
another very important thing i think if
you like to look into geodesic convexity
in romanian many forms
this is an important kind of lemma that
you should take away
so let's just use it and
be happy with it
so
this is the lemma i'm just repeating it
here on this page
and
now
what i will do is
previously this c
its loan was also eta times the gradient
norm so
this distance
we'll call it eta gt
and
the inner product term
is going to be given by
this
as before
so it's the cosine of that angle between
x t plus 1 x t and x star so this angles
cosine
and the corresponding distances those
are like
b c cos
a term right so this is b c times cos a
and we have actually a 2 there so if you
do 2 2 times then you'll get 2 b c cos a
so now
what we do is
this quantity was on the left hand side
so maybe i should just quickly once go
back it's kind of messy to go back sorry
about that
is
this quantity is on the left hand side
and that is like 2bc cos a
so that's what i'm doing
okay that's on the left hand side that
is that part is like 2 bc cos a with the
eta this one is without the atom
and if you take this to the left hand
side
then a square will come to the right
hand side so you get
b square minus a square
and then you have this
zeta
times the c square
and you get that exact bound uh
highlighted in yellow
and once you have that this is really
the telescoping bound we needed the rest
of all the steps work through and you
get the
convergence rate which slows down now by
zeta and zeta is something that
worsens as you get more and more curved
but that building block lamp already
replaced the
law of cosines with a curved space
analog of law of cosines
and after that you can really push
through the analysis
and you get
rates
of course that depend on curvature but
in the convex case you have one by t
here you get you get exactly the same
things
and
when we got that including for
stochastic gradient subgradient strongly
smooth everything goes through like that
and
that made us feel that okay so we found
a lemma which makes all the euclidean
convex results just go through
plug and play more or less in the
romanian case and
i think that was
our initial premature
celebration because
that's not the case you do run into
bunch of other obstructions
for a variety of other methods and
i'm kind of out of time but i'll mention
to you
some space some places where such
obstructions come up so there's a famous
method
in euclidean stochastic optimization
called ssvrg and sag and shga
those methods
kind of
get you fast stochastic optimization
method in the euclidean case
you could plug and play and crank the
machinery to get similar fast methods in
the remaining case but
there is still an open problem in there
that
somehow
the constants
are far from optimal
and that constant so far from optimal is
something that does play
a bunch of the rimanian existing
rimanian analysis and you know constants
are far from optimal
is not just something that in
optimization we brush under the rug
because if you remember
l by mu the so called condition number
is also a constant and going from l by
mu to square root l by mu
is one of the most dramatic achievements
of first order optimization
uh from gradient descent to accelerated
gradients
so that that comes up when doing this
erm type problems
and
the barriers are ex
are described in our paper on that topic
the actual open problem which is right
here but anyhow i'll skip it in the
interest of time
and i'll close by mentioning which
nikola also hinted that it turns out
that
even the initial euphoria suggested that
we can power through
the and crank the analysis and get
accelerated gradient descent turns out
that getting accelerated gradient
descent in many forms
was
a challenge for many years and many
partial attempts
arose including one of our own
partial attempts from 2018 which looks
at this type of you know this is you
nestoro's iteration you replace all the
euclidean concepts with the pneumonian
concept you get romanian version but to
analyze its rate of convergence was open
so
in 2018 we managed to
get one analysis that yes uh
with
for the nicest case smooth function
strongly geodesically convex you we
could only show that in a small ball
around the optimum you get the
accelerated rate otherwise you don't
and then later
in cold 2020
we found a method which gives you
global acceleration that you're faster
than remaining gradient descent at all
times
but it had a strange conditional rate
that initially you're strictly faster
and after a small number of iterations
you reach the full acceleration
and
in light of the lower bound recently
that
by hamilton and mytra that nicola also
hinted at seems that this is probably
the best possible result uh rate that is
sorry not result as possible rate
essentially and but the cool thing is
the method is implemented
and
so an implementable method that gives
you essentially i guess
the tight rate
accelerated rate uh is very interesting
but this kind of marks the beginning of
the study of acceleration theory of
acceleration in curved spaces and
there's lot more i think to be done
there
and
the fact that you have these conditional
results
makes it even more interesting
and
i'll
stop here with a list of references to
other basic topics related to
optimization and g convexity and such
things
and i encourage you to check these out
so that you
in particular
please read this paper
so that you do not make
the errors that many
authors have made
in in pub including in published papers
when they
failed to
use the
complexity theory properly in many folds
and i guess the final thing i would
probably mention here
elephant in the room
uh what about duality and so on so i
think with that i'll stop because i'm
already few minutes over time and maybe
after some questions you you all are
probably waiting to grab some snacks
thanks
well
are there maybe
one or two quick questions
please go ahead
i think you mentioned at the beginning
of the talk that uh
g-convexity implies that local minima
are also global
or a converse or a partial converse
that's known to that result
exactly so you asked the question which
i
kind of schemed early on
uh
but let me let me see
there is a partial converse of
motivating converse actually to that
which i
probably let me unskip that slide and
see if you can see that slide
so
it's
this is the kind of partial converse
which is
you know our
convex function is the only exception so
you can have a kind of a result of the
following style
that if
on a nice set let's say it's a compact
set
uh your function satisfies the property
that local optimum is global optimum in
fact a bit stricter suppose
your only stationary point on set a
is
local optimum and that's the that's
global on the set a then there exists a
choice of potentially non-linear change
of coordinates under which f will appear
geodesically convex
this is basically
echoing the kind of thing that nicola
mentioned you know
a function kind of
having this unique minimum property
is a topological property which is
independent of the arbitrary geometry we
place on that problem and what this is
saying is if on a nice set you have this
unique minimum property then out of the
infinitely many geometries you can place
there exists probably an infinitely many
different geodesically convex geometries
that you can place on it
now which one i should place how to
construct it explicitly is it
attractively doable computationally or
not
i don't know so that's why i kind of
skipped this slide but just as
really high level motivation i hope this
answers your question
thank you
i think there was another question well
it was just i was going to ask if it was
constructive their proof
so for those of you are interested i
mean people i don't studied myself but
you know people study this study morse
theory like
it's essentially most theory type of
result but now you can try to write it
in terms of riemannian language if you
want
because it's not only geodesically
convex we can really parameterize f to
be
to have
geodesically convex riemannian geometry
i mean you could also put you basically
other geometries
by necessarily romanian
maybe let's just take one more question
uh
recently um
no mostly here it was to do with
connected compact etcetera type of thing
so yeah
okay thank you so
i guess
one question from uh i think there's a
hand raised by
andre
that that's me if the if there's time uh
yes so maybe you did this kind of very
shortly but um so you said something uh
like you can use this for uh i guess for
mixtures of gaussians like what's the
flavor of the result can you prove
something like the i don't know the
maximum likelihood losses do you
definitely convex in some major private
reserves no no no no no so that's why i
kind of skipped because i know people
who do theory of gaussians may
think i'm making that type of claim but
i'm not what i did was
that was a purely
it's still a fully non-convex problem
however
the aim there was to
challenge the standard em method with a
method that is numerically more
competitive and
is built made more competitive by
exploiting geodesic convexity of
single component mle
just like em exploit single component
mle in the m-step
gotcha so so like about in terms of uh
speed i guess like it and maybe like in
terms of speed because i just wanted to
kind of challenge this old claim that is
hard to beat em basically that was the
only motivation and once you have
optimization on your side then uh you
could do you know
rimanian sgd ramanian blarimani in
parallel whatever to actually have a
competitive method and what i did not do
yet which is an important kind of
exercise worth doing
is
just like for em you can prove things
like this is this uh nice paper from
siva and when he was at berkeley on you
know
uh
after how after you've seen enough
number of samples within some local
regime
the maximum likelihood the population
likelihood milloku convex and you can do
it blah blah so here
uh what i'd like to understand is that
if you use the rimanian lens and i think
andre you're probably best positioned to
be able to answer that type of question
based on your recent work
uh
is potentially the region within which
you
reach
a convexity structure because now you
are giving yourself more than euclidean
convexity as a structure is the radius
of that region potentially larger or is
the sample complexity lower if one could
answer that that would be a great
contribution to
the romanian view on gmms but i didn't
go in that direction yet
yeah i agree
thanks okay
well thank you so much for for the great
talk let's take silver
tickets thank you